welcome I'm Ian Shapiro
delighted to welcome not only everybody
in this room here today but the the
folks in the to overflow rooms upstairs
which I'm told also full who will be
watching our proceedings on video and
before our before our proceedings get
underway let me just take this
opportunity to invite everybody who's
here to join us for a reception
afterwards on the second floor in the in
the lounge area to continue what I think
is going to be a very interesting
conversation that we're about to start
so welcome all we're delighted today to
be the hosts of nicholas kristof as the
speaker for the 13th coca-cola world
fund lecture at Yale the lecture was
established in 1992 to support endeavors
among specialists in the intersection
between international relations
international law and the management of
international enterprises and
organizations and it's hard for me to
think of somebody better qualified to
speak at those three intersections than
our present guests YC is sponsors this
event along with the law school and the
school of management mr. Christophe as
you all know is an op-ed columnist at
the New York Times he graduated from a
university to the north of here in 1981
and then won his first class honours in
his study of law at Oxford on a road
scholarship he later studied Arabic in
Cairo and Chinese in Taipei he's lived
on four continents reported on six and
has travelled in well over a hundred
countries Mr Kristof joined the new york
times in october of 1984 initially
initially covering economics after that
he served as a business correspondent
based in Los Angeles as Hong Kong bureau
chief as Beijing bureau chief and his
Tokyo bureau chief for The Times in 2000
covered the presidential campaign and in
particular governor then governor Bush
and he's the author of the chapter on
mr. bush in the reference book on the
president's 1990 mr. cristoffen and his
wife Cheryl whoo dude whoo done also at
times journalists won a pulitzer prize
for their coverage of Chinaman's
Tienanmen square democracy movement they
were the first married couple to win a
Pulitzer for journalism mr. Pulitzer is
one other prizes including the george
polk award and the overseas press club
awards Mr Kristof and and Miz who done
are the authors of China wakes the
struggle for the soul of a rising power
and thunder from the east portrait of a
rising asia the title that Mr Kristof is
chosen for today's lecture is is the
first genocide of the 21st century
reporting from Darfur I am very pleased
to introduce Nicholas Kristof
thank you well thanks very much as a
Harvard Graduate it always gives me
great pleasure to come to one of the two
best universities in the country
although we may not agree on exactly how
we would draw that hierarchy and also I
just heard a moment ago that Yale
actually today announced that it was
investing itself of stocks that has
nothing to do with Darfur so the timing
is particularly apropos and I'm also
particularly glad that I the context
here that we're talking about is
genocide today because I think there's
often a tendency to speak about genocide
as something in the past and then to
recite the mantra of never again but to
define again so narrowly that it would
only apply to a German national
socialist named Hitler trying to come to
power and in fact of course the best way
to honor the victims of past genocides
isn't just to build museums or memorials
or invite journalists to talk but more
broadly to try to prevent the next gen
aside from happening and raising
awareness of Darfur and learning more
about it is surely one of the first
steps toward that although also i hope
not the last let me try to place this a
little bit in a historical context in
1915 armenians were being slaughtered
and Woodrow Wilson with absolute
determination looked the other way then
in the Holocaust of course FDR refused
pleased to bomb rail lines leading to
Auschwitz something similar happened in
Bosnia and in Rwanda famously the
Clinton administration refused to even
use the word genocide because it was
afraid if it did then it might actually
have to do something and today President
Bush for his part just about doesn't let
that word Darfur passed his lips
so in effect we have a long and
bipartisan and consistent record on
genocide of inhumanity well I first went
to Darfur just about two years ago
almost exactly and I didn't know what to
expect I arrived from the chad side of
the border and on the chance at an
border I found thousands of people who
all told pretty much the same story
they'd been driven from their villages
by Sudanese government aircraft
attacking those villages and then by a
Janjaweed militia opening fire with
machine guns burning huts often with
people as still inside and these people
these refugees whom I spoke to were
hiding out from the Janjaweed which was
still periodically attacking them but
mostly the Janjaweed was staying by the
wells because this is an arid area
largely desert with few sources of water
and so the Janjaweed militia members
were staying by the wells and when men
would show up to get water they were
shooting them when women were showing up
to get water they were raping them and
what struck me more than anything else
was the moral choices that these
refugees were forced to make and in
particular they were sending there are
very small children there are eight year
old kids there are ten year old kids
four miles across the desert with
donkeys to get water from the wells
because often the Janjaweed wouldn't
bother the youngest children and it
seemed just appalling for any parent to
send their kid to face a danger like
that and yet and I realized that if I
were in that situation I'd be doing
exactly the same thing that they had no
choice well then image I know kept
haunting me and as a columnist it seemed
I should be gallivanting around other
parts of the world preferably you know
Europe but I couldn't get that though
some of those images out of my mind and
so I went back a few months later I went
hundreds of miles further to the north
to an oasis
in in the the far western part of Darfur
this time I found about 30,000 people
and they had nothing and they were all
sheltered under trees in this oasis kind
of one family under each tree and I went
tree to tree and just started talking to
people about their experiences well
under the first tree I talked to two
brothers one had been shot in the neck
and in the jaw his jaw had essentially
been shot off he'd been left for dead
his brother had been just shot in the
foot and had managed to run away and
that night came back to the village to
go through the bodies found his brother
still alive carried him back on his back
49 days traveling only at night to get
to this oasis and you know the hope that
he would be able to get treatment for
his brother under the tree right next to
that one there was a woman whose parents
had been shot in her village and then
the body stuffed in the well to poison
it which is routine in these village at
acts then I the about a shiba and hiding
in the hills and the Janjaweed had found
her family and had killed her husband
and other male members of her extended
family under the third tree there were
two small children a four-year-old girl
carrying her year old baby brother on
her back their parents had been murders
they were orphans and under the fourth
tree there was a woman whose husband had
been killed her two young children the
youngest just a baby both killed and
then she and her two sisters had been
kidnapped and gang-raped her two sisters
had both been killed she had been
stabbed on the leg to be effectively
mutilated to stigmatize her forever as a
victim of rape and then left to left
naked to go back to to the rest of the
community to add to the to the terror
there
and what may be overwhelming more than
anything else was you know those were
the first four trees that I went to and
everywhere in every direction as far as
I could see there were more trees and
more families and more people who had
stories just like that and it was kind
of at that moment that the scale of what
was going on really hit me well you know
sometimes I think the total number of
people who have been killed in darfur is
by international standards somewhat
modest we really have no idea what the
death toll has been but a few hundred
thousand is probably as good a guess as
any and now that's within the the margin
of error for the number of deaths every
year from malaria for example and so you
know there are moments when I think
should we really be that focused on door
for as opposed to malaria and AIDS and
all these other things that kill so many
more people but you know I'll tell you
in the course of a career as a foreign
correspondent I've seen an awful lot of
really awful things whether violent or
you know kids dying of these diseases
but somehow there is nothing that
affects me or I think other people more
powerfully than a government deciding on
a policy to choose people on the basis
of ethnicity or skin color and to get
rid of them and I think it's because it
seems like such a breach of humanity of
the bonds of humanity of the fabric of
humanity that it seems particularly
repulsive and in turn create some kind
of particular obligation on us to assert
her own humanity by responding well let
me back up and give a little bit of the
background of what how this happened in
Darfur in a place that we'd never heard
of you know a couple of years ago there
has historically been
tension in the area among the peoples
there it's an area that is marginalized
and never has gotten adequate attention
or resources from the central government
in cartoon and the division there tends
to be threefold at one level it's
between Arab tribes and non arab tribes
and their the distinction is essentially
that an Arab is somebody who's mother
tongue is Arabic and and the others
speak tribal language and often also
speak Arabic but there has been some
intermarriage in particular there three
non arab tribes the for the muscle eat
and the Segawa so that's the first
cleavage in a region the second is
indeed racial that in general the Arab
tribes tend to be somewhat lighter
skinned than the these African tribes
and the third is the division that you
see all over the world between herdsmen
and settled farmers in general the Arab
tribes tend to be nomadic herdsmen and
the members of these African tribes tend
to be settled farmers and those create
their own you know their own clashes and
in particular the spread of the Sahara
Desert and shortage of resources it has
led to more clashes over water grass and
this kind of thing so you had a real
headache for the government in you know
in Darfur of the of competing groups but
the government in Khartoum is you know
it's it's an Arab government and
completely supported the Arab tribes in
Darfur who steadily became more and more
abusive and brutal to the non arab
tribes and finally in beginning of 2003
the non-arab tribe stage an incipient
rebellion and at that point the Sudanese
government in effect went completely
nuts they decided I think that you know
the Sudanese authorities are not Taliban
style nuts they're they're really
pregnant
calculating people and I think that they
figured that the simplest way of dealing
with this rebellion in the middle of
nowhere was to completely depopulate the
rural areas of of these tribes that were
supporting the rebellion and they
figured he was in a remote area nobody
would really pay a huge amount of
attention to it and they would solve
this this problem once and for all they
they chose as the the leader of this
Janjaweed militia a man called Musa
hello and he he doesn't mince words he
he was quoted in a recent book about
Darfur is having expressed gratitude and
I quote for the necessary weapons and
ammunition to exterminate the African
tribes in Darfur unquote well these days
you travel through Darfur and it is just
eerie eerie and scary you go for mile
after mile after mile and you just see
burned-out villages one after the other
and the village is consist of of these
conical these circular mud huts and the
might of course doesn't burn so those
those mud foundations are still standing
the thatch roofs have been burned you
know people have fled in chaos and so
their possessions sort of strewn around
here or there and so as I'm driving
through these areas I you know it's it's
a little bit nerve-wracking if somebody
sees me their first instinct is to flee
in other direction my first instinct
when I see somebody else is to flee in
the other direction and so interviews
become a little bit difficult but there
are a lot of people still living in
these in these areas these no-man's land
who are not getting any kind of aid and
are completely being hunted down by the
Janjaweed we have very little idea of
what is going on in large areas of
Darfur
that that aid workers and African Union
cannot reach now the government claims
that the fighting in Darfur that what is
happening essentially is just tribal
warfare and the State Department our
state Department has unfortunately used
some of that same language and you know
there is an element of truth there there
is genuine tribal conflict but to
describe what is going on as just tribal
warfare is you know completely misses
the point of the the way the Sudanese
government has armed the Janjaweed and
given them this mandate to kill on my
last visit my most recent visit to
Darfur in November I was driving along a
road coming back from a massacre site
where the Janjaweed had slaughtered a
whole bunch of villagers and I was on a
road where there were indeed a bunch of
Sudanese government soldiers um and
indeed one of those soldiers had kind of
forced his way into my vehicle well as
we're driving along we see and pass a
convoy of the Janjaweed these same thugs
who had just been busy murdering
villagers well the soldier is neither
the one in my car or the ones at
checkpoints all along the road they had
no interest in the Janjaweed because of
course they're all cooperating but
meanwhile at one checkpoint my vehicle
was stopped and the secret police tried
to arrest my Sudanese interpreter they
pulled him out of the car pulled him in
an interrogation Hut and told him told
me we're going to hold him for
investigation you go on nothing to do
with you well you know it was pretty
clear that their investigation of him
was going to end up with him being dead
pretty soon so of course I refused to go
they then decided well that meant I
should be detained as well
later they called a higher commander and
we were both released but it was so
clear that if the Sudanese government
just applied the same restrictions to
the Janjaweed that it applies to foreign
journalists now this genocide to be over
in a moment this is completely happening
with the collaboration with a mandate of
the Sudanese government well is this is
this genocide there's been some argument
that it shouldn't qualify as genocide
because it doesn't because there's no
determined effort to exterminate every
last member of these African tribes the
food is Agha when the muscle eat and
that is it's basically true that the
Sudanese authorities are not trying to
exterminate every single member of these
tribes there's a reasonably determined
effort to kill men and say teenage boys
with others if people run away then you
know sometimes they're killed sometimes
they're not but there's not it's it's
not as if there's a fanatical effort to
destroy absolutely everybody and because
of the Holocaust we tend to think of
genocide as something that is an attempt
to exterminate everybody but in fact if
you look at the 1948 Genocide Convention
which defines genocide as quote acts
committed with intent to destroy in
whole or in part a national ethnic
racial or religious group as such
unquote then that's exactly what's going
on in Darfur there was no the Genocide
Convention doesn't require any effort to
destroy every last member of an ethnic
group and likewise raphael lemkin who
coined the word genocide that certainly
wasn't his intention either I it's
somewhat broader than that and by any
legal definition it seems to me what's
unfolding in Darfur is absolutely
genocide what have we done about it
we've been pretty good about supplying
relief aid
um the u.s. in particular has led the
way in that and particularly for people
who managed to escape to Chad and more
than 200,000 people have then if they
get there if they get to a refugee camp
there then we will supply medical care
to patch them up we'll supply food will
supply tents will help them even people
who are stage to get to these large
camps for internally displaced people
with in Sudan itself then we've been
good about supplying food and and other
and pushing for more humanitarian access
to those people what we have not been
good about at all is providing either
security to stop this or just standing
up to this and calling it what it is and
one of the lessons of past genocides is
that this is something that governments
are not proud of that they try to hide
it unfolds in secret and if you shine
some kind of a spotlight on it then
indeed it tends to subside and we
thought you know when in the period
sorry in the period of Darfur that when
it got a lot of international attention
and colon Powell visited and Kofi Annan
visited and people were focused on it
then the level of killings did decline
and then when that tsunami hit in Asia
then all the attention immediately
swiveled around away from Darfur and the
level of killings in Darfur immediately
ratcheted up word again and more broadly
this kind of humanitarian relief while
you know it's great as far as it goes
there are hundreds of thousands of
people who are alive today because we
did provide that but it still feels just
incredibly deeply unsatisfying when you
travel around Darfur one woman aid
worker told me a story that it is has
always haunted me
she was working in an area where the
Janjaweed were still active still around
and she she visited a village with the
permission of the Janjaweed too and they
had a little assessment mission and they
they called together the villagers and
kind of asked you know had a public
meeting and asked how everything is and
of course everybody said ho you know
things are ok and it was obvious to her
that that this was not the case so she
managed to get two of two member 24
tribeswoman two sisters apart and with
her interpreter asked them so you know
so what's happening and they said that
in their household the Janjaweed had
shown a but taken over their house and
had effectively tour turned their family
into servants of the Janjaweed and so
they had to go and get food and cook the
food for about 12 of the Janjaweed and
these two sisters had to sleep with the
Janjaweed and finally after about two
weeks of this the father of the two
girls he just he just finally he
couldn't put up with it anymore and he
found the commander of these men in the
house and he went to the commander and
just begged him you know please let my
daughter's leave this village please let
them go and the Janjaweed commander at
that point brought the two sisters in to
the same room and then beheaded the
father in front of them and what this
aid worker said was you know this is an
area that I can reach this is an area
where the international community is
still active and these kinds of things
are still happening and that it's great
to provide relief but unless you also
stand up to the atrocities then it seems
so woefully insufficient well why don't
we do more
I think they're there are a lot of
reasons I think that one problem is that
frankly we don't it's not before us you
know this is happening in a remote area
it's not on our television screens and I
think that television more than anything
else would make a huge difference in
rallying some kind of international
response and the Sudanese government has
been very clever about keeping
journalists generally out of the area
some of you may know that I've launched
a campaign to sponsor Bill O'Reilly to
send him to DAR forward to try to get
more coverage and you know that was
partly tongue-in-cheek but it but not
entirely I mean it would make so much
difference if somebody like him went
there and but I don't just want to pick
on him I mean television in general has
completely dropped the ball CBS Evening
News last year devoted two minutes over
the course of the entire year to
covering Darfur and in contrast for
example the three broadcast networks
each averaged 28 minutes to covering the
michael jackson trial you know I can't
tell you when the Michael Jackson trial
was happening I just wish there could
have been a change of venue to Darfur
you know so that finally it could have
gotten some attention or when the
runaway bride case you know if that
runaway bride it only shown up in Darfur
then you know then the network's would
have figured out a way of getting there
and it would have gotten some coverage
but frankly this is a it's a historic
problem then in general we in the news
media haven't done a good job and my own
paper the new york times during the
holocaust we published a 24,000
front-page stories of those guess how
many were related to well referred on
the front page part two attacks on jews
and by the nancy's 66 out of 24,000
so genocide is something that it
historically we haven't particularly
distinguished ourselves and covering I
say the press is done somewhat better
job in Darfur the written press has what
we really need more of is photos and and
above all television that would make a
huge difference I think that at some
level there's also you know a sense for
the lack of political response here is
that it's hard for Americans to identify
with people in Darfur and you know part
of that is skin color I think that if
people in Darfur we looked more like
average Americans than I think that that
America might Middle America might rise
up a little more care about it more but
i think there's also at some level just
a sense that you know here we are in a
you know the world's only superpower
were sophisticated we have this sort of
you know very highbrow moral sense and
you know that Africa is always a mess
these tribes are always fighting you
know it's too bad but you know but but
they're so different from us and that
argument it's not usually framed quite
so so openly but i think that is
widespread and that just burns me up
more than anything when i travel in
Darfur the on one of my visits i visited
a little village called I'm casera and
spoke to a woman whose two-year-old
child had been pulled from her arms and
beaten to death in front of her and she
had escaped to this place called um
kosarin she had another child there and
this is a this is a place in the middle
of nowhere the Janjaweed is running
around a Sudanese military is running
around it's completely unsafe and she's
asking me you know so what do i do
should I try to set out for coma camp
and hopes I can get there and they're
international aid workers there or do I
I you know do I stay here and you know
what will the rest of the world do or
you know is the rest of the world ever
going to help us and you know so what am
I supposed to tell her that well you
know
you know we in the West don't really
want to help you because frankly we're
morally superior and you're you know a
bit depraved it it you know it so flies
in the face of everything you see there
Gandhi was asked at one point what he
thought of Western civilization and as
you may know he remarked he thought for
a little bit said I think it would be a
good idea and you know at times like
that in places like I'm costura I think
it would be just so important and would
make such a difference well why is
President Bush not speaking up more
firmly about Darfur you know it's
interesting because this issue is not
one that is intuitively on the left or
on the right and in fact it was really
the right who initially noticed what was
happening in Darfur because evangelicals
in particular had been very attuned to
Sudan because for years Christians in
the south of Sudan Sudan had been been
slaughtered and it was evangelical
Christians who were you know jumping up
and down about that and so they were
among the first to notice when when when
violence began to break out in Darfur
and people in bushes agency for
international development a ID we're
calling for the White House to do
something long before the Democrats ever
noticed but the White House has never
managed to to get its act together on
this to do anything much about it I
think there are three reasons and I
think that if President Bush were here
and were trying to explain his passivity
I think he would anyone the cameras were
out I think he would make three
arguments I think first he would say
that the the most important thing we've
done in Sudan was to end the north-south
Civil War there which is completely
different from the door for fighting and
that north-south Civil War killed two
million people over 20 years
and indeed to his credit President Bush
really did manage by using political
capital because it was something he
cared about he did manage to bring a
tentative peace there and you know more
power to him for that and I think that
he's considering that if we put too much
pressure on the Sudanese government that
that will in turn i jeopardize the
north-south deal well I think that is
completely wrong and indeed I think at
this point the administration
increasingly acknowledges it that in
fact Darfur is threatening to unravel
the north-south deal and you can't have
a successful deal between the North and
the South when you've got genocide going
on in the west of Sudan that just
doesn't fly the second argument that I
think he would make is that the priority
of the administration has to be fighting
terrorism and that Sudan has indeed been
provided a lot of cooperation in in in
providing intelligence about terrorism
and in cooperating and stopping terror
financing and I think that's largely
true you know that's an important thing
we have to worry about but it can't be
the only thing and for example we
brought the US brought the head of
Sudan's intelligence organization SLA
gosh to Washington by private plane for
consultations about terror and that's
great but he's also as much as anybody
the architect of the genocide in darfur
of all of these atrocities I've been
talking about now you can't conduct
business as usual with people like so
let gosh just because of one item on the
agenda and the third reason i think that
the bush administration has not been
more active is this sense that it's a
mess it's hopeless that there aren't
good solutions it's easy for a
journalist to you know to jump up and
down about it but the policies really
are hard and you know that was basically
the same reason that Clinton didn't want
to do more about Rwanda its reason
presidents historically been so passive
on genocide and at some level they're
right it is a hard problem I don't know
if something
read Samantha Power's brilliant book
about history of genocide it's titled a
problem from hell and it is you know
these in every case it happens in a
remote area and governments we have very
little leverage over but I think that
that's giving up way too early now the
north-south deal in Sudan that really
was a hard problem the South wanted
independence there was significant
amounts of oil involved in Darfur on the
other hand it seems to me a piece of
cord is much easier to achieve the
rebels in Darfur don't want independence
they want greater autonomy they want
more power sharing and the distance
between them is something that we can
help overcome and in particular we often
managed to send signals that are just uh
just incomprehensible at the end of last
year we took out 50 million dollars and
from a conference report for spending to
help fund the African Union forces in
Darfur and there's no better way we
could have sent a message all over the
world that we don't really care about
this than to take out the funding for
these African Union peacekeepers who
can't even take flights around because
they're running out of helicopter
helicopter fuel because their radios
aren't working you know providing that
50 million dollars in funding should
have been an absolute no-brainer and
there are all kinds of little things
that the bush administration can do and
you know one of them is simply speaking
up if President Bush were to bring some
survivors of the genocide to the White
House to meet with them and to speak to
television reporters that would help put
it on the agenda internationally and
instead when aid groups have tried to
bring survivors to this country to get
them out there the US has made it very
very difficult for them to get visas
there have been photos taken of
atrocities all around Darfur and those
are sitting in locked file cabinets
and indeed there's one young American
named Brian steidel who was out there as
a advisor to the African Union and he
got so fed up with this that he leaked a
bunch of these just horrifying photos of
two year old kids with her faces bashed
in with Kalashnikovs buds and he
released them and in the State
Department threatened to sue him for
releasing these photos I mean they
should have been celebrating his action
I think that I you know at some level
the government will respond only when
the public it does and and after the
rwandan genocide Senator Paul Simon the
late Senator Paul Simon said that you
know if just one hundred people and
every congressional district had written
to the member of Congress and said we
got to do something about Rwanda then
that would have changed the political
calculus and an Americans would have
responded I didn't guess largely true
today that you know there's no
constituency out there that is calling
members of Congress and saying you know
please don't do anything on genocide in
darfur there's no countervailing
pressure it's just a matter of getting
enough to push the White House members
of Congress to do a little bit more and
so you know if you want to know what to
do then I think the most useful thing is
simply to make noise in to bellow and
once there is a certain level of outrage
then politicians will follow and will
determine policies that will make a real
difference and simply that level of
scrutiny and concern and alarm makes a
real difference on the ground I mean
here at Yale there's a organization
called Stan which is active in Darfur
issues they're holding a letter-writing
campaign later I think a vigil there's
information outside and there are lots
of other groups through saved our fur
org there's genocide intervention
network they're all and any aid group is
active is active there if you need a
push then let me just leave you with
with the story of a woman I'm
at last summer in a camp called calma
this is a woman called mug bula and she
was from a little town she was quite
prosperous and then all of a sudden one
day the Janjaweed attacked her village
and the sudanese air force attacked her
village and her family was enabled they
weren't able to take anything with them
but they they escaped safely and they
hid in the hills then a a couple months
after that the Janjaweed found the
family in hiding they they caught them
they held him at gunpoint they killed my
goolies husband in front of her
tormentor eight of the men gang raped
her she then her only concern was how do
I keep my children alive and every
thought was you know if I can just get
through this then I can take my kids to
a camp where there will be international
aid workers and she had her smallest
child was just an infant very very young
and so when these men left her she set
out across the desert with her children
of this long Odyssey she finally got to
come a camp which is the biggest camp
probably in all of Africa at this point
and but the Sudanese government at that
point was refusing to accept new
arrivals and so wasn't refused to
register her and so she couldn't get you
know food distributions she couldn't get
help in building a hut or anything else
she was just sleeping out there in the
sand and a few days after she made it to
coma and finally you know in the embrace
of the international community aid
workers there then her youngest baby
died so think of mug boola think of
about two million more people like her
who have been displaced and they're the
people whose lives we hold in our
hands thank you very much and I'd be
delighted to take questions
okay yes sir is there a religious
dimension to the conflict my guess is
the people in other rooms can't hear the
question right okay let me let me repeat
that the question is whether there is a
religious element to the strife in
Darfur between the government and and
others and in this case there is not
there was in the north-south conflict
where the the north of Sudan is Muslim
and the south is either christian or
animist so that was very much an element
of the north-south conflict in door for
everybody is Muslim and so that has not
been an element of it one of the things
that I just can't understand is why
other Muslim countries in the region
haven't spoken up more about Darfur it
would make a huge difference if Egypt
for example which has huge influence in
Darfur would you know would speak up
about it if the arab news media would
raise it more I think that one of the
problems has been that an aftermath of
Iraq in particular that anything that is
raised in the u.s. immediately attracts
so much suspicion that it kind of lacks
a lot of it doesn't have a lot of credit
of credibility and I think that has been
frankly one of the the problems in in
getting other Muslim countries to to
raise issues of Darfur
the question is whether there's any
prospect of getting NATO involved I hope
so it's right now most people in at
least NATO would say no and people in
the US government were generally saying
no but what's happening on the ground is
we have an African Union force seven
thousand peacekeepers only 5,000 of them
actually with with weapons and the
weapons they have our ak-47s they're
hopelessly outgunned the the guns we'd
have heavy machine guns on the backs of
pickup trucks that fire three times as
far as these little ak-47s that the
peacekeepers have the sum of the time do
we even have artillery the AU forests
you know it was great that it went out
there but it's way too small it's
outgunned it's been a failure that's
gonna be a little strong because there'd
be a lot more people dead if it weren't
for them but but it certainly has not
stopped the tragedy what everybody is
now kind of now kind of agrees has to
happen is that that force has to be blue
had it in other words it has to become a
UN forest and idea is that there would
be that the African Union peacekeepers
would stay there and then you would
bring in others to make it a much larger
force under the auspices of the UN and
there is general agreement on that but
it's kind of agreement that well in
about a year we'll have a UN force there
and you know in the meantime not much
will change I think it would make
tremendous sense to have a NATO force
there as a bridging forest you know in
between the two and I think if the US
were to really push for that I think it
would happen I should say that I don't
think that it makes sense to send us
ground troops into Darfur again in the
aftermath of Iraq I think that that
would arouse just tremendous hostility
and suspicion around the Arab world i
think the sudanese leaders be able to
say you know those American imperialists
are launching a new crusade against
their
you know rise up and defend the
motherland and so I think that that
would be a mistake but I think that you
can have a very robust international
force with Muslim troops from Turkey for
example with troops from and equipment
from Russia ideally from Japan Canada
Germany it'd be great if China sense
them to bring China into that China has
been one of the great protectors of of
Sudan and this playing a totally
disgraceful role and but you know NATO
would make nado nado could do this it'd
make a great difference they were too I
sure hope it will happen as a bridging
force but I sure wouldn't bet on it the
question is what is the president of
Slovenia doing and how can we help him
well you know it's it's amazing to to
watch the you know the politics of
Darfur and my reporting usually goes you
know where i talk to somebody and one in
one government or in one administration
and they describe how much they're doing
and how you know little everybody else
is doing and you know everybody is
passing the buck and in this absolute
vacuum of leadership the president of
Slovenia of all places has emerged as as
a real leader and everybody else is kind
of contemptuous of this effort I mean
you know Slovenia but I mean I take my
hat off to him I mean slovenia is
slovenia wants to be interested in this
and wants to talk about these issues and
he I mean the president of Slovenia who
whose name I can't pronounce because he
desperately needs more vowels he but
he's he's he's been you know he came to
New York to meet Kofi Annan he wanted to
meet President Bush President Bush I did
not want to meet with him
and again the lost opportunity you know
I could have just met utter the word
Darfur invited men for you know the
pressing for a a photo op but but he's
also the president selena has also got
you know some celebrities involved in
this little quixotic campaign he's
planning a trip to Darfur and he's
offering to take television cameras with
him which is very useful because it it's
very difficult for us to get visas into
Sudan and so we can either try to
accompany some official get a visa that
way or we can sneak in illegally from
Chad and not I'm their problems with
both options but but but but that
ability to bring people in is great and
I don't know why our government and
other leaders you know why they're sort
of contemptuous about the president of
Slovenia doing us when you know we
should be celebrating him and inviting
into Washington to talk about how we can
bring other Europeans in and and and so
on one thing you didn't talk about was
any kind of international legal remedies
and a year ago we had a lecture here
from the chief prosecutor of the ICC
International Criminal Court and gave a
pretty harrowing account of how under
resources that are and that they can
really pursue you know one or two bodies
in there that they really can only
pursue one or two cases at a time and
they really try to pick them to be as
strategically efficacious as they
possibly can but this seems like such an
obvious candidate for them and I
wondered if if you'd had any either
thoughts about or interaction with the
ICC and the prosecutor's office and what
what might be going on there sure um I'm
a great admirer of Louis ocampo the
prosecutor but I'm I'm actually much
less I mean in general I'm kind of
you know multilateral list always wring
my hands over some kind of issue that we
should all be you know talking about
actually the ICC I'm less enthusiastic
about then I think a lot of other people
of similar ilk and for basically two
reasons one is that I you know if
resources are scarce and you can apply
the marginal 50 million dollars to
trying to keep people alive in Darfur
say as opposing to as opposed to
providing accountability afterward then
I think that if that is the trade-off
and it's not a perfect trade-off but
there's something to it then then I
think really should be a higher priority
and secondly I think that accountability
does provide some deterrence sometimes
but typically the danger for a Janjaweed
leader in a place like Darfur or Liberia
of Sierra Leone so and is that you're
going to be you know shot tomorrow as
opposed to ending up before an ICC
tribunal in a few years so I'm somewhat
skeptical of the advantages and the and
the other downside is that it can
complicate a resolution of a problem and
in northern Uganda for example that once
once you actually are trying to
prosecute somebody that is harder to
reach a peace treaty with them if they
think they're going to be facing
prosecution for example so when I
approach the issue with a certain amount
of skepticism about about the ICC but in
this case I thought that that it was
useful to have to refer for the Security
Council to refer the prosecution of war
crimes in Darfur to the ICC and that's
basically because you know it's one
thing we can do to bring a little more
attention to atrocities there to
genocide there and in the absence of any
other effective measures it does help
put it on the international agenda to
some degree it did get Sudan's attention
Sudanese leaders are genuinely scared
about that and so yeah
lewis ocampo is proceeding full speed
ahead with his investigation and more
power to him
the question was about domestic Sudanese
politics and whether people in other
parts of Sudan know about or
particularly care about victims of
atrocities in Darfur and the answer is
generally kind of they don't know much
or care much in the north in in the Arab
parts of Sudan there's a natural
tendency to identify with you know the
Arabs in Darfur and you know it is
genuinely true they often complain that
the the news media and you know
international figures always talk about
the atrocities suffered by the African
tribes and ever about the atrocities
suffered by the Arab tribes and indeed
there are some but there is a certain
lack of quality there I mean them there
were you know I'm sure there were some
SS men killed by Jews in Europe but
trying to create some kind of parallel
there i think is is its kind of absurd
and that's that's the situation that
they're the try the African tribes some
of them have harmed some Arab tribes but
but but few and and much less than the
way around the in the south we were and
also that I say them in Sudanese news me
it is so controlled that there isn't
really any effective reporting you know
either by foreign media or domestic
media about what is going on in Darfur
in the south of Sudan we were really
hopeful that after this tentative peace
agreement between north and south that
once you brought southerners into the
government that then they were going to
put pressure on the government to reach
a deal over Darfur and they have not
been nearly as helpful as we had hoped
or thought I think part of that is
because you know they are mostly
christian or animist and they don't
particularly identify with Muslims who
are getting killed in darfur there they
have their own problems which are
enormous that agreement may fall apart
so it's hard for them to get excited
when they've lost two million people of
their own about you know a few hundred
thousand who have been dead so far in
Darfur and so the bottom line
unfortunately is very little sympathy
internally in Sudan the one exception
which is interesting is the Armed Forces
that disproportionately the Sudanese
military is composed of African tribes
people from from Darfur members of the
four tribes Egawa tribe and so on and
that indeed is one reason why the
Sudanese government decided to resolve
this not by using its own Armed Forces
but by using the Janjaweed that it
wasn't sure that it could rely on for
soldiers to slaughter for villagers who
knows if there's any unrest in the
Sudanese Armed Forces you know we'll
know it when there is a mutiny somewhere
I but I I would not bet on that
think the question is whether the
Sudanese rebels the rebels in Darfur the
dark were rebels could whether they
could be play a role analogous to that
of the rebels in Rwanda who in the
context of that genocide ended up
endings genocide by taking power or
whether there's a realistic rebel force
in Darfur that we could help and and
empower in that way and I'm afraid there
isn't the rebels have behaved
atrociously on their part they have been
their leaders been mostly sitting in
abuja the peace talks have been in Abuja
and Nigeria and both sides been sitting
in these nice hotel suites you know
enjoying life there and getting nowhere
and not really negotiating seriously and
in over the last six months or so the
rebels have been fracturing themselves
and often shooting each other spending
more time doing that than actually take
me on the Janjaweed so I have very
little hope for the rebel forces and you
know they they're they're real thugs to
a lot of them I was struck in one of my
one time when I sneak in from Chad I
drove into a rebel I outpost to a
village who was guarded by some rebels
and the commander I you know you warned
me gotta give us a call in or a Sat
phone if you're gonna be driving around
here because you know when we see
something moving we tend to shoot it you
know it was supposed to be the good guys
the well I don't think that there is a
realistic you know process there that we
can provide military other support to
their our tribal shakes in Darfur both
Arab shakes and and non-arab shakes and
these guys they don't have the guns but
they have tremendous moral Thor
authority and legitimacy in
the context of Darfur and right now the
peace process I think has largely
ignored them that effectively these
international talks have involved the
government Sudanese government and then
the rebels and those are the two most
recalcitrant parties and I don't think
we're going to get a piece a peace
agreement out of them I think though
that in my ideal scenario on that front
would be that Kofi Anan would appoint
colon Powell as a special envoy Colin
Powell I think really cares about Darfur
at the end of his time there he didn't
early on but toward the end of his time
of Secretary of State he really began to
care about Darfur that if he would go
out there and pretty much bypass the
Sudanese government and the rebels and
talked to the tribal shakes then there
is a traditional conciliation mechanism
in these villages I know because people
have always been stealing each other's
camels and sheep and there there are
ways of resolving those and it seems to
me quite plausible that that kind of
foreign intermediated talk would
actually get somewhere that shakes on
both side are sick of what's going on I
mean obviously the shakes of the African
tribes they had their people being
slaughtered their living in camps they
want to have this behind them and the
Arab shakes their migration patterns
have been have been hugely disrupted and
while they stole vast amounts of
livestock they kind of depended on on
markets they were operated by these
african tribesmen and and on crops that
were raised by people in African tribes
so they're alive Lee has been hugely
affected too and I think that that the
Arab tribes would be willing to work
toward some kind of a a piece to as long
as you could just bypass the Sudanese
government and the rebels and you know
would that work I don't know but it's
surely worth a try
right for that the question was what
impact is the Darfur in rest having on
Chad next door just to the west and that
is that's a great question it's one that
is very fuzzy but one thing that hasn't
gotten nearly enough attention is that
it seems as far as we can tell that
Sudan is about to sponsor an invasion of
Chad using basically a proxy army the
the present president of Chad president
debbie was installed by Sudan years ago
and traditionally that's that's what
happens that Sudan you get this you know
rebel forces in Sudan will kind of
support and then it will race across the
desert to the capital of Chad and Jimena
and then take charge and the problem
even though President debbie was
installed by Sudan he is a member of the
Segawa tribe and there's agama tribe is
one of those being slaughtered in Darfur
so he he hasn't been entirely supportive
of that and Sudan has been getting he's
been standing up a little bit more and
so finally Sudan has been getting sick
of him and so there is a large forests
of their nominally Chadians there in
theory these are Chadians who fled Chad
and are mounting you know a rebel force
I'm sure an awful lot of them are
Sudanese you know the tribes are on both
sides of the board is hard to tell who's
what they're very well equipped somebody
who was there recently told me they had
2,000 jeeps jeeps and technicals these
pickup trucks with heavy machine guns on
the back there you know there may be an
hour's drive from the Chad border
they they say that they're going to
invade Chad and overthrow President
Debbie and I I'm I would take them at
their word I think that in I think it's
very likely very likely more more likely
than not then in the next couple of
months that we will see them attack Chad
and possibly i'm in the best case
scenario they will surgically overthrow
President Debbie and there'll be a
little lunch 'less between Sudan and
Chad and Chad will be and I'll never get
another visa to chat again I guess but I
you know then the fear is that then the
international community won't get access
to these two hundred thousand-plus
refugees on the chad side but it it
could be a lot worse than that I mean
the chad civil war could reignite the
people in these refugee camps in the
chad side could be you know completely
slaughtered the giant the Janjaweed over
the last month or so is making daily
raids across the border from sudan into
chad and you know the and essentially
the whole international community just
hasn't wanted to deal with with this
with the prospect of Chad being in
effect swallowed up you know made
another client state again of Sudan but
it seems to me a just a reflection of
the degree to which our policy and the
whole world's policy toward Sudan has
failed that after all that that they're
willing to mount an invasion a proxy
invasion of a neighboring state
the question was whether the French have
have real interests and traditional
interests and a major base in Chad not
far from the Sudanese border and you
know wood wooden a proxy invasion of
Chad by Sudan you know would that get
the French to stand up and maybe use a
Foreign Legion um I don't think so the
French have been really wimpish on
Darfur and pretty unhelpful and I'm I'm
not so sure exactly why but they have of
the Europeans they've well of the
Europeans the Russians have played the
most disgraceful roll the French you
know come in second on that front the it
would make a lot of sense if the French
base air base in eastern Chad and I
pêche a were used to impose a no-fly
zone over Darfur and you know they've
they're horrified at that idea and I
don't think that they would you know
blink if if this invasion force came
waltzing through
the question was about what kind of
relief efforts are active in in in
Darfur itself in and Chad there in
general they are overseen by the UN and
all the aid agencies are active him and
you go you in a town like nyala in South
Darfur you know you go down the road and
one compound after another is you know
save the children its care its
international rescue committee it's
there's there's a new restaurant in
Nyala catering you know Westerners never
used to go to Nyala but there's there's
now a new restaurant catering to the aid
workers to this you know invasion of aid
workers in Nyala sir is actually pretty
good pizza and since it's basically the
only restaurant in Nyala i won my last
time there I I walked over and I counted
about seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars worth of SUVs parked outside and
you know I didn't know what to think
about that I mean in a place where
people are just dying because they can't
get anything it just seems like an
incredible least strange use of
resources on the other hand you know
these aid workers who were in Darfur I
mean they are risking their lives every
day it's a nasty area they're getting
harassed every time they leave niala you
know those roads are dangerous places
they're getting shot at so it's hard to
begrudge them you know a nine sixty
thousand dollar SUV but the you know
something is still wrong in that kind of
allocation of resources but it's
effectively all the all the aid groups
are are active in both Darfur and Chad
the problem is security that their large
areas now that are no go areas where
you get either Janjaweed or bandits and
they and then you know aid workers can't
go and indeed I mean one of the things
that you know we people talk about I
mean a little bit hush-hush I hope
there's no Sudanese intelligence
official here to send this idea back
it's one reason why i haven't mentioned
it to calm but one of the real fears is
that the government of Sudan will decide
that all these foreigners in Darfur are
just too much of a headache they're
complaining too much and the simplest
way of getting rid of them is you you
know you machine gun some of these
people out in the middle of nowhere on
one of these roads and then it's not
obviously you know the Sudanese
government won't obviously have their
their fingerprints on it they'll blame
it on bandits but then in that kind of
situation aid workers will have to be
pulled out and if that were to happen
the UN estimated that a hundred thousand
people a month would die in Darfur and
you know I think there's there have been
times when there have been hints that is
happening whether if it attacks on
compounds on aid agency compounds in
some of the town's when there have been
attacks on convoys and even a USA USAID
employ a young woman was was shot in the
face last year you know so there have
been some of these incidents they're
scary and I sure hope that it doesn't
come to that kind of attack they would
just drive away all the foreigners
um the question is you know what is the
population of these tribes and if if the
giant we did take a Nazi approach to
things then you know what kind of death
toll would it be the again we don't
entirely we don't know an awful lot of
things about Darfur including good
population figures the estimates tend to
be maybe six million people in Darfur
and the majority and maybe as many as
two-thirds members of these African
tribes and you know and less than half
and maybe one-third various Arab tribes
and there are some tribes that are that
are hard to place there there's a one of
the largest Arab tribes the bugger Arabs
have been have not been involved at all
in fact they sheltered some of the non
African tribes and also people in the
cities have in general even if there's
my African tribes they've in general not
been targeted it's really people in
either rural areas or in these camps who
are most at risk and indeed even in the
areas that the Janjaweed has completely
controlled they found it useful to have
farmers to let some people survive so
that they can have farmers farming so
they can have some markets and so it's
you know it's if things go very badly it
won't be you know all say four million
non-arabs being killed in darfur but I
suppose you know you could certainly
have a death toll of a total of a
million or more dying in Darfur alone if
it spreads into Chad you know you know
another million or so one of the reasons
we you know we know so little about what
is going on and we there have been some
interviews with people tried to
calculate death toll for Darfur it's
deeply unsatisfying one of the things
though that just gets me every time I go
through one of the camps
in Chad or in Darfur proper is you look
at the camp population and they're not a
lot of males it's overwhelmingly women
and children or old people and you know
some women and children are getting
killed but it certainly is
overwhelmingly men who are being killed
and I think the reason by and large that
you're not seeing them in the camps is
that they're dead the question was about
these three tribes in Darfur do they
work together and the tribes the for the
masa lead and the segawa initially they
did to some degree and there are some
tensions among among them well but
initially when they were being wiped out
they really did cooperate but over the
last year or so they've been splintering
and in particular the four and the
segawa tribes have been splintering
along in the rebel force along tribal
lines and so they've been shooting and
torturing each other and you know that's
been its added to the whole mess of
Darfur I think that the Sudanese
government has made some kind of
calculation at this point that's how
it's going to put this behind it that
the rebels are just going to collapse
and be defeated militarily and that then
it will you know completely control the
whole area and that these areas of rural
Darfur essentially will you know that
they will never be repopulated and there
have been real efforts to destroy
infrastructure poison the well as i
mentioned destroy irrigation programs
destroy schools in a way that you know
you get the sense that there's real
effort to completely change the
ethnicity of the area
our melon on such a role as a word if
the Sudanese government is fine ashamed
of pressure um the question is you know
given that the fact that the Janjaweed
are is so well armed and you know if I
you know even if one were to shame the
Sudanese government would that really
change the facts on the ground and
that's it's a fascinating question I
mean there is a real the Janjaweed are
really full of themselves now they're
feeling is you know the Sudanese
government the Sudanese army couldn't
tackle the rebels couldn't tackle the
problems in Darfur so they called on us
and you know we did it and they're
militarily they're very well equipped
they've you know rocket launchers
artillery every gun you can imagine and
this is in an incredibly inhospitable
area and it's you know it's hard for a
conventional army to fight in and so I
think that if the Sudanese government
were just to try to crack down on the
Janjaweed just like that you know it
would have something of a fight on its
hands but the saving grace of this is
the Darfur is deeply tribal and you know
there r shakes and the shake are they
have I mean they do command loyalty of
everybody below them and so if you can
convince the leading shake that they're
you know that they need to to stop the
slaughter then that word does filter out
and and that's what effectively needs to
happen and I think that it indeed can
happen you get rid of you know a couple
of the shake like Musa hello the guy who
I quoted earlier and you know put
somebody else in his place and the
Sudanese government has been doing that
kind of manipulation of the tribes I to
me the last best hope in Darfur is those
shake on both sides
they go back to their wives and children
sighs
um the question was about the Janjaweed
and you know what kind of people are
they whether I've had contact with them
and today after going out and
slaughtering people in a village they
just go back you know to their families
I've had somewhat limited contact with
them thank goodness it's you know it's
really kind of it's really scary
sometimes because you're out there and
you know the I mean one time some local
tries people they pointed out a camp in
the distance and they said that's the
Janjaweed camp and you know I thought
about driving over and i am from the new
york times but you know it just didn't
seem like a great idea and so but i have
i mean i have had some contact here and
there especially in the cities and i got
a sense of a couple of different things
that there is an element within the
china to weed and particularly the
leadership it is really pathological
these are people who had long histories
of murdering people often because of
their ethnicity it involved in
massacring people they didn't like one
of the ways they staff to Janjaweed
early on when they were forming it was
by opening up the prisons and bringing
out thugs completely antisocial people
and then i think is one reason why you
get some of the most brutal kinds of
actions i mean it's very often you get
kids tossed onto onto burning under
bonfires for example you get a lot of
mutilations and I think the debt is
coming from this real pathological kind
of thuggery then you also get a lot of
these Arab tribes people and they are
much more nuanced and when you talk to
them they say you know you know that
these people have been you know building
their farms they've been taking our
water we've been here forever and then
they've been you know planting their
crops and it gets in the way when we
move our livestock around when there's a
drought we can't get enough water for a
livestock and then they'll always cite
some example of their camels being
stolen by you know those for villagers
and they're all crooks and and this kind
of thing but they're they're embarrassed
by the degree of killing and you get the
sense that you know it's it's kind of a
mob scene and that a lot of those people
that they could return to a kind of more
normal life and put it behind them and
that Darfur could you know start over
with kind of that segment of the
Janjaweed okay one final question
okay i'm dan st was asking about the
larger african trajectory and you know
is it over the last 25 years or so since
dan and i backpacked around Africa
together has it you know how does it
seem different and I'd say that in
general it has been consistently pretty
depressing that it's interesting when
you talk to development experts and I
spent most of my career in East Asia and
if you talk to people who spend a lot of
time at development work in East Asia
they're kind of bubbly and optimistic
and enthusiastic and you talk to you
know people who spent their careers in
Africa and it's like you know you know
they just they their sense of you know
it's a struggle to keep anything going
and is the only region of the world
where per capita incomes have declined
steadily for decades now I think that
has been particularly exacerbated by by
aids and HIV that if you hadn't had that
happen I think that a lot of Africa
would look much more promising but I
mean it's also a reflection of the
governance problems that that aids is so
bad in much of Africa the one thing that
I I mean I say there are a couple of
things reasons for some slight optimism
one is that I think it African countries
now have a much better sense of what
policies work that in the 1960s and even
in the 70s there was a flirtation with
Sir planned economies to Kwazii
socialism and you know at that point it
wasn't entirely clear what kind of
policies we're going to work maybe
import substitution would work and now
now we kind of know that doesn't work
and we have a better sense of the
policies that you don't overvalue your
exchange rate you try to have economies
that are more open to the world you try
to encourage a little more for
investment and so on and so and we do we
do have more African success stories
including some leaders who have done you
know a pretty good job botswana now is
consistently done just a great job
mauritius has done a great job uganda
ghana rwanda in general I think have
also shown that you know there can be
real successes unfortunately some of the
leaders of these places that had looked
promising and Uganda is one good example
at the moment I you know that leaders
just stay out you know if only President
Museveni had a heart attack five years
ago he would be remembered much more
fondly Eritrea is just a country it's a
wonderful country and it seemed so
promising a few years ago when they took
power instead of putting up a statue of
their of their new president they put up
a statue in the center of town of
sandals because all the revolutionaries
had worn sandals and it's the coolest
you know statue you can imagine but now
now their leadership is just you know
turned into real thuggery again so in
general in contrast to almost everywhere
in the world and latin america could be
the only place that sometimes leaves me
depressed as well for similar reasons I
you know I I don't it's hard to be
optimistic but Africa as a whole but I
do think that you know there are some
particular countries that have worked it
out and that do shine some kind of a
light to others about what works and
security in general has improved outside
of places like Sudan and Chad West
Africa's in somewhat better shape than
it was that promising the African Union
has been involved to some degree in
Darfur even though it doesn't condemn
you know what's going on in Zimbabwe for
example so the glass is half full thanks
very much
you